he's an author businessman and
motivational speaker known for his
theories on wealth and motivation he's
the author of secrets of the millionaire
mind which appeared on the New York
Times and Wall Street Journal bestseller
lists he found that the seminar company
peak potentials training he's T Harv
Eker and here his top ten rules for
success money as a result okay that's
what everybody doesn't understand money
is a result you're the cause that's the
effect you are the root of your success
people have saved me all the time hey
Harv how do I be successful how do I be
a success I said if you want to be a
success you have to be a success
you have to be the success when you are
the success then everything you touch
will be a success everyone can be rich
action but a lot of people say well I
don't really want to be this and I want
to do what it takes to be rich what I
want to be comfortable now that's the
problem right there by the way because
comfort and convenience are the kiss of
death to success so you have to be
willing to be uncomfortable in order to
grow and all that means is that you're
going to be able to do something
different than you've been doing before
if you keep doing what you've always
done you're cute getting what you've
always got
you got to switch it up but that's the
problem the problem is most people can't
switch it up they want to and they will
for exactly one day if they're good
maybe today but it's hard to keep it up
why because we're creatures of habit you
will need to change your habits don't
try to change them all at once but what
happen you're going to have to change
one name habit at a time now people just
change one habit I promise you this your
life will change
I just want entrepreneur number one
you're in the right place at the right
time but it has to be the right you in
the right place at the right time number
two very the why I say that is because
the definition of an entrepreneur or a
person in business or even a person in
the job is a person who solves problems
for people at a profit or for pay so
what are you you are a problem solver
the biggest mistake almost everyone
makes in the world of business
finance and money is they go out and
they look for opportunities
bad move go ahead what's an opportunity
how do you know it's almost impossible
to mine like so don't look for
opportunities look for problems look for
problems solve a specific problem for a
specific person duplicate that the end
result is rich if you want to be rich
don't focus on money don't focus on rich
focus on solving a problem a specific
problem for a lot of people imagine for
a moment you're with a 5 year old child
and you're walking on the street and you
come across this ice cream store and you
go into the ice cream store and you
order this single scoop of ice cream on
a cone because they don't have any cups
now you give it to the child and of
course because they're only 5 years old
they have little hands and they kind of
just wobbling out the door and and just
as they're out your nose are going out
the door the door hits their hand and
the scoop of ice cream falls on the
ground of course they get very upset
they begin to cry and being the kind and
generous person that you are what do you
do you go back into the go into the
store and just as you're about to order
this other scoop of ice cream the child
sees the poster of the triple scooper on
the wall and they go I want that triple
scoop and now because you're kind of
generous person what do you do do you
now get them the triple scoop or you
don't no of course not why would you set
them up to fail they couldn't even
handle one scoop putting a load of down
with three scoops though now you might
be laughing except for one thing there's
a universe the universe and the universe
has a principle of Management and the
universe says this until you show you
can handle what you've already got you
won't get any more the Bible says the
same thing - he who have more shall be
given
most people are running around with one
or two scoops dripping all over the
place they have a financial mess on
their hands and they have no foundation
and they go what give me more give me
more give me more and the universe in
its support of you is saying not until
you clean that up every decision you
make comes from you it's your decision
so whether you make a lot of money or a
little money are a result of the choices
that you make and the actions that you
take right so they all come from the
root of you so literally we're talking
about the possibilities that when you
invest in yourself when you invest in
your mindset your attitude when you
invest in your character when you invest
in learning more about your habits and
changing those habits when you invest in
your personal development you know
you're going to take a shortcut to that
success because as I said it could take
2025 years to get a big return on your
financial investment but how long does
it actually take to get a return on your
personal growth investment well it's
different for everybody it depends on
what kind of tree you are all right what
I mean by that there are some trees that
when you plant the seeds they just
sprout the next year they go from you
know from nothing to two feet in a year
and then they just keep on going and
they grow to a certain height okay let's
say this height but then there's other
trees take the bamboo tree for example
or the bamboo story where basically you
plant the bamboo seed and a year later
you come back and you check on your
bamboo tree there is no tree how come
because still under the ground two years
later you come back and you come check
on your tree no treat there's nothing to
see three years later no treat four
years later no tree you start to wonder
there's no tree here this thing must not
have taken hold the fifth year you come
back not only do you see a tree you see
a tree that could actually be 50 feet
high in only one year how come because
what was it doing for the four previous
years it was growing its roots really
really deep
really really strong so that it could
handle that extreme skyrocketing growth
when it came out of the ground so a lot
of you are fast going trees from the
very beginning but you got to have
stamina that's why you have to keep on
working on yourself you have to keep on
investing in yourself so that you don't
just grow and then plop over by the
first wind that goes by right and a lot
of you are you are bamboo trees you are
growing deep deep roots and then you're
going to all of a sudden sprout grow
really high and you'll keep it because
your roots are deep one way or the other
you have to invest in yourself you have
to keep growing play to win rich people
play the money game to win poor and
middle-class people very often play the
money game not to lose they play the
money game on defending it say yeah they
play on defense versus offense they're
big intention is is to have enough to to
pay the bills and on time would be kind
of a miracle right and you know what if
your intention is to have enough to pay
the bills if you'll notice that's
exactly what you're going to get we are
always looking for the complicated
things to do you know look for it's got
to be complicated that's hard and
success is hard and you know where we
sometimes get quite focused on making
sure we do the hard things but sometimes
isn't it true that it's the easy things
that you know we have that we could do
that by not doing them things become
hard they become difficult life becomes
difficult so the goal is to do the easy
things in life but here's an example we
all know that we should eat our
vegetables eat more greens eat healthier
is that a hard thing is that a
complicated thing no it's a simple thing
do you do it most people no they don't
do it and they don't do it enough so
they give that up a little bit of
exercise we know that do we do it for
most people no they don't they don't
necessarily do it calling people back
answering emails being an integrity
keeping your word being on time keeping
your agreements I'll get this to you
tomorrow do you do it well hopefully you
do but most sometimes we don't and
they're not hard they're easy but the
easy
things that we don't do that make life
hard so the big insight here is that
things that are easy to do are also easy
not to do when we come into the world we
come in as an empty vessel you don't
know anything you've got no information
and here you are this empty vessel is
empty glass and all of a sudden you come
into the world and the second you get
into the world you get filled up with
information from who everyone and
everything all around you so pretty soon
you are a factor a result of this
information and so why do you think the
way you think
what does anybody think really thing
because of the information that is
stored in the files of your mind your
mind is nothing more than a big old file
cabin it stores information and so
literally the only thing you can think
is what's in the files of your mind and
the only things in the files of your
mind is what you learn what you were
told the information that's in there you
cannot pull out a file of a file cabinet
that's not there and that's the
difference between successful people and
unsuccessful people successful people
have filed in their file cabinet that
are files that lead to success when
Donald Trump makes a decision normally
that decision results in success so why
is it that his decisions result in
success he has trials in his mind that
are success based on well fixed file
norm it's normal natural brand it's
natural for most rich people because
they have files in their file cabinet
called their mind that result in actions
that result in success mostly drug the
opposite why because most people learn
about money about success about
happiness from people who aren't
successful well being happy
so if that's what you learn what do you
expect so what do you do well you need
to reprogram need to relearn you need to
put some new information in the files of
your mind and then you need to have some
new actions from those files and you
will get new results you say hey Harv
it's easy for you to say that you're
really rich well you know what
wasn't always rich and it's because I
did that because I was going to take a
shot on me that I am really which you
know I came from a place where I wasn't
not only the nicest guy in the world but
I thought I knew it all but I didn't
know anything right I didn't know
business I thought I knew that but
obviously I didn't I didn't you know I
was I was a very angry guy I was very
into that very nice to people I was out
of balance I was you know doing lots of
things that were very poor habits and
literally I learned how to succeed
that's the cool thing about this you can
learn to succeed at what at anything you
can learn how to be a piano player I
don't know anything about piano but I
bet you in one year I could learn how to
be a piano player how well you say by
practicing right yeah but I could
practice for a whole year to learn a
song and it still might not even get why
don't I take a shortcut
what's the shortcut get a t-shirt get up
professional piano teacher to teach me
how to play piano and in one year I
could learn lots of songs I could do
that you could do that anything you want
to know and be good at you can do you
can learn how to do it remember every
master was once a what every master was
once a disaster so you can learn
anything there's not one thing that you
know that you want to get involved in if
you want more money you can learn how to
do that if you want better relationships
you can learn how to do that you want
better health you learn how to do that
you want to better use if I learn how to
be happier you can learn how to do that
every one of those things is a learnable
skill you know one of the things that
I've had running since wealth and wisdom
is that it's true that you know the
truth is that sometimes I don't feel
fantastic sorry sometimes I know and
sometimes I'm a little upset a little
frustrated you don't have the emotional
parts to come out anybody else relate to
any of this yes sometimes once in a
while well let me see this right now so
I get a little support and a little
support comes in the form of these words
don't forget to wear your awesome
glasses and those are glasses that on
the front of everything you everything
you look at through those glasses is
what everything is awesome
all right they're special glasses you
put them on everything
awesome now the question is does that
work the question is is that a bunch of
BS or is that cannot actually translate
into reality how many you say you can
actually translate into reality
why wouldn't translate into reality
because you have a choice you're going
to look at things a certain way anyways
yes or no you don't have a choice about
that you're going to look at in a
certain way the only question is can you
remember to look at them in an awesome
way can you look at the good in it
that's all you have to you know can you
do that and and the awesome glasses help
us do that so everybody right now I want
you to take your glasses hold them right
here look at them and notice that they
say awesome right on the glasses right
right on it all over them everything is
awesome about these glasses there's no
anything I want you to take these
glasses and I want you to put them on
and I want you to see the world I want
you to look at your friends
and say you're one you're awesome
everything you look after these glasses
is what awesome though they're here help
you to help remind you yes now again we
can make up a story that says yeah
that's a bunch of crap or we can make up
a story says no I choose to look at it
life this way and the question is which
is true and which is false and the
answer is neither are true or false the
answer is that the way you look at it is
the way it is yes sir yes nothing has
meaning except for the meaning we want
so we choose to make give it the meaning
of awesome we choose to give ourselves
the meaning of awesome we choose to make
the program what program is going to be
why it has to be awesome if you decide
us awesome it's awesome now the question
is whether it is or it isn't will you
have a better time if it is will you
feel better about you if you are will
you feel better about the people beside
you if you look at them as they are will
you feel better about life if you look
at it as awesome is there a good chance
that because because you are choosing to
look at make up that story and choose it
as awesome that more awesome things will
be attracted to you because of that more
than if you look at everything in the
darkness and terrible and what's going
to happen then what's going to be
attracted to you
the same I don't see anything that could
be bad about this but I can only see
things that can be good about it whereas
the opposite if you're not sure if it's
working then you have to put on your
life is [ __ ] glasses and you get to wear
that all the time now you choose because
you have the ability to choose a
god-given right to choose which glasses
you're going to wear because you have to
wear one of them
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jeff semper
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of t harv
occurs top ten rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments I'm going
to join in the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon